hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures in
games early reviews are in unlike me
various other film and TV authorities
are considered important enough to see
advanced screenings of Marvel movies
they just give this guy passes to
survivalist bunker for impending
asteroid collision useless let us run
through how people are reacting to
endgame and don't worry there will be no
spoilers in this video I have not seen
the movie yet so it's not really
possible for me to spoil it you know
what I'm not even gonna make any major
predictions explicitly in this video
because I know my predictions have
accidentally been right before and
ruined so many lives apparently I am
despised by some of the Dutch joke my
each doctor ha life only knew is he
holding you will feel Izu in advance on
everything and find all the goodies that
you might have overlooked ENIAC I Kadosh
mu you dimension are what did she just
call me it real quick if you live in the
LA area and you want to see Avengers
endgame with us there are still tickets
available to our special screening at
the El Capitan Theatre on Friday April
26 with an exclusive live taping of our
debrief panel review of endgame and a
VIP after-party ticket info is in the
description below
ok a lot of these influencers social
media reactions tend to skew positive
and generally floored
but parsing through all the language
there seem to be three takeaways so let
us do one less ride with one more pre
endgame tweet down
first no surprise here the general
consensus is that endgame as the
conclusion to 11 years of Marvel films
is super emotional
our very own Maude Garrett tweeted out
that she was an emotional wreck and
can't stop crying and the twinkle in my
right eye Sam basher emotionally rests
in peace and her good bud Erin couch of
The Hollywood Reporter quoted Chris
Evans as saying he cried like six times
similarly Peter Skuratov / film tweeted
that he cried five to six times I just
did that around six teary moments keep
coming up since there are six original
Avengers left standing and I guess by
saying five to six maybe squirt it just
doesn't give a bit about Hawkeye David
it's cop from the New York Times also
felt the field Sweeting I was not
prepared for the range of emotions that
endgame put me through from utter
despair to pure elation I laughed I
cried
I wish Tony Stark was my dad but
hopefully all the moisture you lose from
crying will dehydrate your bladder and
erase the need for a bathroom break
because everyone seems to agree that
three hours is a lot of movie bringing
this to our second takeaway in-game
story will be incredibly complex Lindsay
Barr of The Associated Press said
endgame moves along very briskly
considering just how much story there is
Beatrice Verhoeven of The Wrap said all
the theorizing didn't prepare for this
and hopefully she was talking about us
because I have done quite a bit of
theorizing on this channel and you know
I'd still like to be a bit surprised
film critic Kevin McCarthy tweeted some
quite verbose praise of in games
complexity saying it's truly
mind-blowing how beautifully paste this
storytelling is perfectly balanced as
all things should be he went on to say
that anything that could be confusing is
always explained with purposeful
exposition this film shouldn't work as
well as it does so it sounds like the
movies 3 hour runtime isn't just
indulgent Marvel fanservice
I suppose in games dense complex plot
structure necessitates a full 182
minutes to unfold we may be looking at
something similar to the famously long
run times of Christopher Nolan films
like Inception and interstellar which
featured delicately layered story
structures that required some effort and
time
to wrap your brain around and that
complexity leads us to our third
takeaway endgame will be packed with
connections to MCU past now that's not
really a spoiler folks because every MCU
movie from the first Avengers to Captain
Marvel is filled with Marvel Easter eggs
and tie-ins with other MCU installments
like freakin Wakanda popped up in Iron
Man 2 all the way back in 2010 but if
you're worried your overactive
imagination will spoil the movie if you
think about it too much feel free to
pause this right now one of the more
interesting things tweeted about endgame
came from Erik Davis of Fandango
he called endgame a true culmination of
22 films that not only concludes the
story but expands upon it you'll learn
more about the other movies while this
one unfolds
if infinity war is the braun endgame is
the brains and wow what an ending and
wow what a tweet down we're about to do
on this sucker Davis actually continued
do not go in expecting an infinity War
part two the two films are so different
yet complement each other in all the
best ways in terms of which MCU movie to
watch beforehand honestly all of them so
a lot of keywords pop out here it
expands upon the story of the infinity
Saga you will learn more about all of
the other movies brings yeah I have made
plenty of other videos explaining these
specific ways in game could do this so
no need to rehash it here but it sounds
like the callbacks to MCU history will
be especially important in this finale
in screenwriting you always want your
final act to look backward and recycle
elements from before if you can re
implement callbacks and surprising ways
it gives your story a full-circle
feeling like how the final Harry Potter
story brought the battle back home to
Hogwarts and all the other familiar
faces return to fight or how in
Inception the final 15 minutes is mostly
repeated visuals dialogue and symbols
that were introduced earlier and it
sounds like Avengers in game will be all
about this kind of nostalgia I'll leave
you with the reaction from Kevin Paula
we from Yahoo entertainment who promised
cameos throwbacks and haircuts so you
don't need any leaked footage or
spoilers just re-watch all the Marvel
films bring some tissues and strap on an
adult diaper and you'll be good to go
now we will be making a few videos
but in-game after it comes out but we
will do our best to warn you about
spoilers in case you can't see it right
away but if you haven't already gotten
tickets for the first day again there
are still seats available for new
rockstars special Avengers in game
screening this Friday join us for an
exclusive live taping of debrief
afterward where we will review this film
and a VIP afterparty ticket info is in
the description below follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA vas and
subscribe to new rock stars for
breakdowns of everything Marvel related
thank you for watching see you after
endgame and hold on to your brain
[Music]